[Music]
[Applause]
Steve Palazzolo our good buddy pro
football focused senior analyst and host
of Pro Football Focus NFL podcast and
we've got our power rankings coming up
for this upcoming season after the draft
PFF has their
Power Rankings okay where do we get a
surprise here with the best teams in
football Steve
I think it's got to be the Browns at
nine you know so when we're running the
numbers on this there's there's a lot of
data that says to Sean Watson is a good
quarterback and he only played the five
games last year he wasn't great but I
think the Browns have a pretty strong
all-around roster they've done a good
job just building depth over the last
couple years and then it's going to come
down to DeShaun Watson so our numbers
still say hey there's far more good than
bad on his tape even though the good was
way back in 2020 so the Browns being at
nine in our power rankings probably the
biggest surprise I think give me the
chamber teams that improve the most and
affected their rankings in the off
season
it might be obvious but the Jets they're
up at six for us and again it's it's so
it's so quarterback driven you know we
have a spot on our site that says uh not
it puts our power rankings together and
then it shows okay the quarterback is
worth X number of points basically so a
Patrick Mahomes might be seven or eight
points on say the spread which of course
is going to affect your ranking by about
you know 15 spots basically for the
season so Aaron Rodgers you know going
from a Zach Wilson Joe Flacco uh Mike
White team to Aaron Rodgers who again
may have regressed a little bit last
year but you know there's far more good
data for Aaron Rodgers he's the biggest
impact player to move this off season so
it moves the Jets way up and they
already had a pretty solid roster around
him anyway what was the grade on Rogers
by Pro Football Focus last year
I believe he finished in the high 70s so
which was you know good not great you
know he's a guy that coming off his two
MVP Seasons he was in the high 80s low
90s so it's from that Elite area to just
good
um obviously I think with Rogers there
were other circumstances dealing with
the rookie receivers a late breakout
from Christian Watson losing Devante
Adams so all of that stuff has to be
factored in I think as far as context
but Rogers was good not great last year
but I think if he was to bounce back it
wouldn't really surprise me given the
his history let's take Rogers out of the
equation let's look at the talent with
Green Bay and the Jets which roster is
more talented
I think the Jets have the nod right now
it's it's pretty close Green Bay had an
influx they had 14 draft picks I think a
lot depends on how well those guys get
integrated right away but if you look at
the Jets their defense got a huge boost
last year sauce Gardner the number four
overall pick who was the best corner in
the league by our numbers DJ Reed a
corner who they brought in in free
agency last year so that solidified a
secondary that was terrible for years
they're loaded on the defensive line the
Jets they're rolling seven or eight deep
with guys that can rush the passer it's
going to come down to offensive line
health I think for the Jets they've had
they had a lot of injuries last year and
that hurt them but they've got
Playmakers they've got players on both
sides I think the Jets do have a
slightly better roster than the Packers
right now the least talented roster or
rosters can be found where
I think it's Arizona so the Cardinals
and which is why I loved their draft you
know giving up draft picks or get you
know giving up draft position to to look
at next year Arizona is completely
depleted on the defensive side of the
ball and maybe offensively you have
Kyler Murray already he's hurt he's
going to miss time maybe DeAndre Hopkins
isn't there any longer so I think it's
Arizona and then fascinating it's it's
the Rams really I mean the Rams are they
have high ends Talent they have Matthew
Stafford Cooper cup and Aaron Donald but
the Rams depth is absolutely challenged
so those couple years that they quote
unquote went for it starting to see what
happens there where they're depleted
they need a lot of young players to to
step up it feels like there's a
Groundswell and maybe that's overstating
this that
Arizona is going to be bad and next year
they'll be on the clock with the number
one pick and maybe the second overall
pick therefore how could you pass up
Caleb Williams could you see Arizona
moving on from Kyler Murray
after this season I could see it I mean
Tyler it's a little more difficult now
that they signed him it's harder to move
off that contract and everything but
Caleb Williams I think a year from now
you're going to get Patrick Mahomes
comps you're just going to I know it's
unfair I know we we should never use you
know Mahomes or Brady or any of the the
you know immediate Hall of Famers as as
comparisons but Caleb Williams has
Patrick Mahomes types type of plays he's
a great Runner he has unbelievable armed
talent and he's just productive and he's
really really good so a year from now
we're going to be talking about this
great Prospect at a Trevor Lawrence
level and Kyler Murray you know who's
coming off of an injury we might see him
for only half a season yeah that's going
to be a debate a year from now and I
could see Arizona trying to find a way
to just bring Caleb Williams in do you
remember what Pro Football Focus thought
about Patrick Mahomes coming out of
college
yeah so like our overall grading wasn't
great you know if you look at his entire
career and you look at the data nothing
said this guy's you know future
superstar that was last season he did he
did play at an elite level so it was
trying to figure out how do you weigh
that with Mahomes he had quit baseball
which I thought was a factor
um and then when we you know those were
what the hard numbers said and then what
we said from an analysis standpoint
isn't different from what a lot of other
people said it was like Hey the special
is there he needs to learn how to play
Within structure a little bit better and
the upside is immense and then he goes
to this incredible situation with Andy
Reid with the Chiefs and if you read
everybody's Mahomes scouting reports
weaknesses working within the pocket
decision making working with instructor
it was like he took every weakness and
turned into a strength his first year as
a starter so I think a lot of us had the
same analysis on Mahomes and then he
goes to a situation where it was just
perfect for his development did Pro
Football Focus have Mitchell trubisky
rated higher than Mahomes come on Dan
why you'd have to go there why do you
have to go there yes yes we may have we
may have had uh trubisky Watson and
Mahomes it was a mistake it was
obviously a mistake like other people
what did I miss though or maybe I didn't
miss with Mitchell trubisky because I
would watch him in college but I never
came away going man you got to go up and
get that guy where's Deshawn Watson did
everything you want a quarterback to do
beat Alabama win a National Title it's
almost like we saw too much of him and
we we love the man you got to see this
guy well I don't know if Anthony
Richardson is you know like Mitchell
trubisky you got to see this guy so what
was it that trubisky did or didn't do
that everybody fell in love with I mean
looking back I think there were a lot of
concerns about trubisky but there was a
lot of positives and I think one of the
things that in his Camp was the fact
that he was a one-year starter so it
depends on how you look at that as a
one-year starter you think there's more
upside there's more there as a one-year
starter you could also say why didn't he
see the field earlier at UNC people and
against him
um that's the same thing with Will Levis
that makes me nervous same thing that uh
uh you know we got a few that Zach
Wilson Trey Lance I gotta have more of a
sample size than one year well it's
interesting because you know Joe burrow
had more than one year as a starter but
only one year Elite and Kyler Murray was
a one-year Wonder as well basically as a
guy that was sitting behind Baker
Mayfield sitting at Texas A M for a
little bit so it kind of goes both ways
um so I think yeah with the thing with
Watson too if you just really
dissected his game it was a lot of like
one read and then he takes off type of
stuff like he changed his playing style
in the NFL and then again with Mahomes
it just felt like such backyard football
in the big 12. we've seen a three-man
rush half the time it was like well this
isn't translatable this will never work
but you just don't you just don't see
how special they are as far as wanting
to get better in that natural play
making and I think that's where a lot of
us missed back in that 2017 class Steve
panozolo Pro Football Focus senior
analyst uh you guys all in on Daniel
Jones
no I mean I I think he's I think he's in
the middle tier of quarterbacks I mean
so I think we're in a world where
there's enough there's a lot of starting
quarterbacks in the NFL and Daniel Jones
is one of them you know rewind 10 years
I think it was tough to find a Daniel
Jones level starter you know Andy Dalton
was like this cut off where people if
you were below Andy Dalton teams were
trading for you know whoever uh so I
think Daniel Jones is fine I think he's
is he Dak Prescott Daniel Jones are they
on the same level no I think I think Dak
Prescott's a tier higher than Daniel
Jones I think the one thing that Jones
has going for him I don't think he's as
good of a passer as Dak Prescott I think
it's the running ability that Jones has
and the fact that the Giants tapped into
that when he rushes for 700 yards kind
of quietly but he picks up five six
seven first downs per game that stuff
goes under the radar and Daniel Jones
does that extremely well so it's not as
flashy but it's effective that's the one
thing I think Jones has but I don't
think he I think Dak has far more of an
opportunity of carrying a passing game
than Daniel Jones does at this point in
their careers
your anti-running back in the first
round but two went in the top 15 picks
Mistakes by Detroit and Atlanta
yeah I think they're mistakes but it's
also tough to identify them you know
like Bijan Robinson is going to go and
he's probably gonna rush for 14 1500
yards he's going to have 12 touchdowns
and it's going to look like a win you
know saquon Barkley went number two and
he won offensive Rookie of the Year and
everybody's like look pick Justified
um but it it comes down to the wins and
losses right the Falcons already had a
top three or four rushing attack last
year with fifth round rookie Tyler
algier they have the best running back
room in the NFL does that actually
matter in today's NFL I don't know but I
don't know if we're gonna feel it
because the Falcons got so much better
across the rest of their roster it's not
like they're going to win four games or
we're going to say C you shouldn't have
taken Bijon Robinson it's more about the
opportunity cost of other positions so
um yeah I think they're mistakes over
time as far as winning games
um but I get how you can fall in love
with the players nothing against Bijon
Robinson Jamir Gibbs the Lions won same
thing I don't know if you're gonna feel
it I think their roster's so much better
they had four uh five picks in the top
60 or so so you know they're gonna be
better this year but I think over time
you'll feel it a little bit more because
of the opportunity cost of other
positions that they could have brought
in I would love to see Bijan Robinson
use the way Debo Samuel is I'd love to
have him get 800 yards and 90 catches
I'd like to have that Advantage there
where I'm not you know gonna give him
the ball and just pound him but I would
be able to to have those strategic
matchups you know Christian McCaffrey
Devo Samuel that kind of situation and
and I had a scout tell me you know he's
got unbelievable hands and I wouldn't
use him as a primary back he's just a I
would just have him as a weapon his
position is a weapon and use him
accordingly
he is that good I mean you see there's
plays on film where he's running the
scene and adjusting to off-target passes
as a receiver the one caveat to that
though when Debo Samuel who is really a
wide receiver the defense calls him a
wide receiver when he lines up into the
backfield that breaks defenses you have
to bring a corner into the box you have
to you have to just change your your run
Gap fit your your run fits and all that
stuff running backs don't have that type
of mismatch ability as much as say a
Debo who's a receiver by name treated as
a receiver and then plays running back
so it's a it's it's similar but there
are some differences where I think Debo
has the advantage don't be a no at all
Steve okay I'm sorry it was a good idea
Dan it's a good idea once again Mitchell
trubisky you guys love Mitchell trubisky
all right we've all grown and learned
hey good to talk to you as always thank
you we always appreciate Pro Football
Focus that says Steve palazolo the
senior analyst there co-host of Pro
Football Focus NFL podcast